hello everyone here we have a most
interesting game from round five of the
European individual championship it's
played between Croatian Grandmaster even
cherish and also Croatian Grandmaster
Martin boss huge and now you might have
noticed I don't feature players from
Croatia very often on my channel the
last game I featured was the exilim name
it's versus you wanna pour ger or was it
you wanna pour girl vs. name it's either
way the reason is there are a lot of
interesting games played in in the
entire world and it's it's hard to
pinpoint which games to show and which
tournament to follow but this game I
will show you as its it's a really an
incredible game it's a miniature it's
really it takes to to create a game like
this it's not enough for one player to
play really well it takes two players
both of them have to be ready to create
something over the board and then nice
things will happen so here we have like
I said even Charlie Chan do you might
know who most of you might have heard of
him as he he is a bit more famous as in
2008 he won the World Youth Chess
Championship here I even prepared a
photo of this moment it was played in
2008 like I said next to him is a
Croatian Grandmaster Valentina gubenko
who also that year became the world's
women youth champion so a great a great
year for Croatia in chess but you know
sadly not a lot of people in Croatia
heard about this as chess doesn't really
make the media well not these days but
especially not them and he had a lot of
great successes throughout his career in
2014 he won the Tata Steel challengers
tournament he qualified for Tata Steel
masters in 2015 and also he beat Magnus
Carlsen into 2014 chess olympiad and
Martin Bosch which also well two of them
are probably two of the best Croatian
players and I don't know I think even
charge is the highest rated but I don't
I don't know if postage is the second
highest rated I haven't checked but you
know there's somewhere around there I
believe two of them definitely are the
best Croatian chess players and you
might remember both your church as a
Croatia display an excellent tournament
last year in the European team Chess
Championship and won fourth place but
fourth place that was like beyond any
expectation almost won third place you
had the same points with Ukraine but
Ukraine had better additional criteria
and I believe madam Basia future for for
some time he had like the best scorer on
board too but then later and maybe a
rough moment of overtook him but
regardless he played an excellent
tournament there and I remember in round
five I believe he he beat German
Grandmaster Mattias blue blue bomb was
searched you blundered up the exchange
in the opening and then later totally
totally outplayed him with his superior
Bishop Bishop pair and won that game so
definitely an interesting matchup and so
far after four rounds both charged and
both of which have three and a half
points so whoever wins this game I will
probably get a lead in the tournament so
let's see this game but charge has the
white pieces and he opens with E 4 we
have c5 the Sicilian defense Knight to
f3 d6 d4 C capture son d4 Knight
captures and Knight to c6 that amount of
variation Knight to c3 and now going to
c7 the bass recurve Bishop to e3 we have
a 6 and now Queen to d2 nice to f6
queenside castle and Bishop to b4 here
f3 King side castle and now g4 preparing
to push h4 g5 and so on here we have b5
by black preparing to start expanding on
the Queen side and now the immediate g5
9 2 h 5 and now pink the b1 rook to b8
rook to b8 with the idea that if white
starts pushing now even further for
example F for English betwee 2 now what
can go Knight to a5 and later play
Knight to c4 attack the Queen and the
bishop
then the light square bishop will be
forced to grab the night and then
blackwell sorry about that but black
will be forced to capture be captures on
c4 and open up this nice B file for the
rook
so rook to b8 a nice idea now Knight
captures on c6 d captures on c6 and now
f4 so first removing the night and then
pushing f4 c5 Bishop to e2 now attacking
the knight on h5 and the denied that
doesn't really have anywhere to go so
first you defend it g6 it doesn't really
help black anyway to capture on c3 first
white simply recaptures and it's mâche
m-- idea basically
so first g6 now Bishop captures on h5 g
captures on h5 and now f5 and here there
seems to be some ideas featuring Bishop
to f4 maybe hitting that Queen and the
rook but it's for a moment that that's
not really a threat
so simply Bishop to b7 attacking that
efore pawn as the knight on c3 spend
there's no point in going before a 5 and
whites attack is completely nullified
Bishop to g3 now Bishop captures on e4
so that would be kind of pointless
so after Bishop to b7 now the immediate
to g6 you have to capture it of course F
captors and g6 capturing with the h1 is
no better F captures on g6 and now
Bishop captures on c3 and this Bishop
captures on c3 seems to be the mistake
that allows white to start gaining some
advantage better was H captures in g6
and after white attacks this pawn queen
to g2 then first Bishop captures and c3
there's always time for this now white
can't capture back because the bishop
will simply retreat to g7 so after B
captures on c3 now Queen to g7 and it's
a better position for white but perhaps
black could hold this but after this F
captures on g6 Bishop captures on c3 was
played and this allows the in-between
move G captures on h7 would check so
King to h7 and now Queen captures on c3
and Bishop captures on e4 it's a
perfectly fine move and not serving like
to grab the pawn or anything but the
bishop from e4 can come back to the
defense we have Bishop to g6 so here we
have rook H to g1 as the rook was also
attacked on h1 but you know you have to
assume D open G file rook to f5 and this
rook to f5 does give a white a lot of
ideas and there's basically only one
good move for white here so your
attacking here try to continue this
attack with white it's actually a pretty
good exercise this position so feel free
to pause the position and find how to
continue the attack will white so as
usual I will give it a couple of seconds
so for those who found it
congratulations you are an excellent
attacker and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show in this position
charge played a bishop to see one with
the idea of making room on the Queen
with via Queen to III followed by Queen
to h6 checkmate of course white doesn't
have two moves black also get the same
this and here and no reply is actually
good from black but here both which
plays rook to f3 and this is what I mean
one it's not enough one player isn't
enough to create a brilliancy it
requires to both which also wants to
counter-attack he also wants to create
something but this allows a brilliant
finish by by white first Queen to d2 of
course this was expected this was the
idea of Bishop to c1 now Queen to h6
threatens checkmate and there are a lot
of ways to prevent this but basta she
goes for King to h8 and King to h8 how
do you continue the attack now of course
you could go Queen to h6 but then black
will block with Bishop to h7 and then
you still have to figure out how to
continue this attack that's like that's
like a really barbarian approach to the
position so after King to a trade charge
finds the strongest continuation he
plays b3 it's simple but extremely
effective simply opening up this
diagonal for the bishop and the King is
in huge trouble the rook is controlling
the entire G file the Queen and
trying to h6 this is this is insane
so here rugby to f8 was played with the
idea that one of the rooks can block the
bishops attack on the F file via rook to
f6 but now comes Queen to h6 check
Bishop blocks and now again feel free to
pause the pause the video and find the
winning move for white here it's really
an interesting idea you know you'll find
great use in finding this move so for
those of you who found that
congratulations you are once again an
excellent player and for those of you
who still just want to enjoy the show
for whatever reason the movie Irish
played was rocked to d7 a great idea
deflecting the Queen and in this
position Miriam was madam Basia touch
resigned to the game it doesn't matter
what black does of course if you just
move the Queen then Queen captures on h7
is checkmate and if you capture the
Queen then the Queen is no longer
guarding the v square and now the trip
to be to check is is in is an insta-kill
that the King has nowhere to go like I
said the rook is controlling the G file
so first you have to give the give up
the pawn then you block with the rook
and then Queen to f8 check wins the game
rook Bishop to g8 and Queen captures and
g8 this is checkmate
so yeah rook d7 this is move 27 so okay
maybe not like literally a miniature but
I think in in in modern chess anything
down to 30 moves is a miniature so even
regardless of how many moves were played
I will call this a miniature so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and yeah I did prepare the standings
after round 5 of the European individual
championship here we have even charged
after five rounds holding first place
okay tied with him in first place our
time with Nabatean Benjamin Bach but
still an excellent position to be
holding after five rounds then we have
rather Slovakia shocked daniel booko
Toro Gawain Jones and so on and so on
and even Martin Bosch which is still on
this list here we have him I believe it
is xx xx or something with three and
have points out of five but that's also
an excellent position considering you
have 303 players you know well all
together playing the European individual
championship so very nice results for
both of them and you know a beautiful
game created by both of them so that
that's basically it I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank then
Dennis Goods of mark mark Brettschneider
Andrew Rhiannon Joshua Wong Christian
Martin and Manish Parmar for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon